how's it going my name is PewDiePie and
welcome to today's a very special day
because we hit four million Bareilles 4
million subscribers whatever you want to
call late I maybe you are suspecting
something really spectacular well then I
have I'm just kidding I don't have
anything it's just me you ungrateful ass
at now just kidding anyway I started
Fridays with PewDiePie only because I
wanted to get in touch with you bros in
a better way and acknowledged and so to
say and you bros my fantasy was watching
my videos if it wasn't for you watching
my videos I wouldn't even be making
videos in the first place and what if I
wasn't making videos my life would be so
different thinking back on it I would be
doing something I was studying something
that I didn't really enjoy and I I
probably wouldn't even be able to stay
with my girlfriend because we live at
different locations in the world at the
time and it was really difficult and I
love my girlfriend more than anything so
I can't imagine what it would be like if
it wasn't for you bros also I wouldn't
be able to talk about the charities that
women doing I wouldn't be able to be
proud of what we accomplished together
this channel I wouldn't be without you
bros watching I wouldn't even be able to
do what I love to do every single day
and that really means the world to me
I just wanted to take this quick video
to say thank you for it if you stayed
with me a long time you probably heard
me say it a lot it's getting old I get
it but hey I appreciate you hanging
around there Oh gross
sorry I hope I can make more spectacular
video in the future and when I have time
I just rarely have time for something
special with all the videos I upload
it's hard to slow down you know I I
don't know how long I will be keeping
videos but even if this even if it ends
tomorrow don't freak out I'm not gonna
quit making videos and I still feel like
it's been an experience that I will
cherish it for life so for that I want
to thank you I love each and every one
of you stay awesome
[Music]